hi i'm dwanda wise i'm bryce dallas
howard i'm chris pratt my name is jeff
goldblum g-o-l-d-b-l-u-m
oh uh and and this is and you know we're
doing here we are going to all of us
take the buzzfeed trivia quiz having to
do with all and i mean all of the
jurassic movies all of the parks and two
of the worlds yes here we go i had a
tutor come to that buzzfeed tutor yeah
coached me at the house the past six
weeks
let's start off with general trivia isla
nublar did i even say that right
isla new black thank you
it's really tricky it's really tricky
it's off the coast of which costa rica
yeah costa rica are we saying costa rica
costa rica i feel pretty confident
boom correct
okay which dinosaur has not appeared in
the jurassic park cinematic universe
velociraptor velociraptor's been in it
we know t-rex has been in it
dilophosaurus has been in it yeah the
only one that hasn't megalosaurus wait
wait yeah that's right that's correct
megalosaurus
megalosaurus mega loss megalosterous no
he's probably not true i think we're
right
which type of theory does dr ian malcolm
specialize in
is it a string theory b
cell theory c
chaos theory or d
coexistence theory which one is it uh
you do you know chaos
yes okay yeah chaos theory yes you know
you can't spell chaotician without ian
doctor ian malcolm
this is dr ian malcolm yes which
animal's dna i think i know this is used
to replicate the dinosaurs is it a a
turtle
b
a frog c a snake
or d an iguana i know you want to all
say it together rip it rip it frog
frog
we supposed to say it together and you
cut everybody off to wanda
we are honored we can do this we're like
an acapella group ready one two frogs
[Music]
time to get into movie specific trivia
and jurassic park who is the first
person to die on screen is it a ray
arnold b hasn't died dennis nedry that's
how i feel no he hasn't see he's in that
jungle donald gennaro which is how i'm
going to say it janeiro gennaro thank
you see donald that's mario
that's why we're in this together or d
robert muldoon clever girl
i think it's
donald donald was on that tour
on the toilet right
because that's when the things really
pop off is when the t-rex starts chasing
around alan grant and the kids and
that's part of that whole sequence the
two cars get stopped in
i think that's i think that's got to be
it but shouldn't we consult that's
exactly right played by the great marty
ferraro yes
now see this of these four that's the
first person to die on screen but you
know didn't some people die in the very
opening well yeah they but they're
in the lost world jurassic park we are
introduced to dr malcolm's daughter what
is her name
is it lex sarah ellie or kelly i know
the answer to that oh look at you you
know the answer to
the name of your own kid
[Applause]
i feel like this is one of these things
where i wouldn't know the answer to that
because i always forget people's names
the character names her name was kelly
of choice her name was kelly played by
the great uh actor vanessa lee chester
yes in jurassic world we are introduced
to the hashtag raptorsquad what are the
names
is it blue charlie echo and delta is it
beta charlie echo and delta is it blue
foxtrot echo and delta is it beta
charlie echo and tango grady deering
yes yeah blue charlie echo and delta
yeah blue
on donner on dixon on prancer
and blitz is blitzing
i think blitzen sleepy
doc
curly
larry
mo
curly joe what happened ringo
john groucho
and
zeppo blue charlie echo and delta that's
my choice
what happened what happened to beta
in the old days she got eaten oh man but
not not not the beta we come to know not
the better we come to know that's beta
senior that's bader jr junior yeah okay
this is a good one and jurassic world
fallen ginsburg is what is what
jurassic world fallen kingdom dr wu
creates the independent thank you
indoraptor which is a super hybrid
mainly made up of which two dinosaurs a
stegosaurus and a pterodactyl a t-rex
and a velociraptor a triceratops and a
velociraptor or a pterodactyl and a
t-rex indoraptor indoraptor window
raptor so we know that there's
endo raptor yeah that's the second one
so there's
now the indominus rex was also a
combination between a t-rex and a
velociraptor so there's that wonderful
moment yes
i think it's gotta be t-rex and
velociraptor i think i think indiraptor
is yeah i would say this yeah it's t-rex
and velociraptor is that final final
answer yeah should we phone a friend
should we phone a friend what do you
think what do you think i have no idea
i'm like wait let's go let's go
yes you through lucky every once in a
while last but not least which actress
made a small but iconic appearance very
iconic in the jurassic park cinematic
universe i know this exactly
drew barrymore camilla bell dakota
fanning or winona writer she's a little
girl a little girl in in the war and
lost lost world yeah camilla and i've
run into her
since she and she uh she's grown up
lovely grown up into a wonderful
wonderful wonderful person yeah it's
camilla bell yeah it's camilla going for
it
look how perfect we got nine out of nine
i don't want to brag but we might have
been in these movies yeah we could be in
the movie i've been skipping my part why
don't i read more questions oh yeah
the game is over that was it
hey i got one question who got you
gotten all my questions that's probably
me
is that true why are there none totaled
because you were
you might not have guessed this but we
aced it you can see us in jurassic world
dominion june 10th as it opens up thank
you for enjoying this video make sure
you get your tickets now and like and
subscribe follow subscribe smash that
like button this is chris pratt for
buzzfeed let's go